who was other homeboy who
surprised play batman well uh christian
bear was the best batman in my opinion
his voice just his voice bothered me it
was a little fake right
yeah i'm batman he's gotta make a fake
voice you're gonna make a fake voice so
people don't recognize your bruce wayne
yeah they at least have like some mouth
thing did you have a catchphrase or some
people would know
that would be dope if you covered your
face like why do we need to see the
lower chin of batman first of all i
don't think that's a good idea for
protective measures
the chin part is terrible because like
that's the part you'd want to punch and
it would be like so white
if you're in a fight with batman just
shoot for the chin you can't miss it
you think you have camouflage on
everywhere but no spot you get knocked
out
it's like the horrible idea when you
look stupid
it's so ridiculous when you look at it
that's the dumbest idea ever like you're
gonna not protect the most voter how
about just
open open the nose part up too let your
nose get smashed
like that's so crazy that's so strange
it's like bruce wayne from batman in the
[ __ ] like
batman at least he didn't have like a
protective suit on adam west no he just
had the thing over his eyes
he was just in disguise this batman has
gotten to the point where
he's in this like basically it was an
armored suit
and meanwhile he doesn't cover his face
meanwhile he's going to war with
superman
do you know how goddamn stupid that is
and doing work kind of what does that
superman is from another planet he can
fly so fast he makes the world
spin backwards he makes time goes
backwards
he can cut things in half with his
eyeballs he's got laser shoots
pick his dumb ass up and carry him as
high as he wants and lets him go
yeah and he came over movie's over he
could bring you to the sun
yes throw you into the sun you [ __ ]
talking about
hollywood he's got [ __ ] on my face
how how crazy is the idea that gravity
is so dense on superman's world that
when he comes to earth he can fly
and then the atmosphere is so different
that his body's bulletproof but he looks
just like us